what up space fam golden here from anime
outpour and today i'm going to be doing
a video i've been planning for a while
a video talking about every hokage and
their powers i've been a naruto fan
since elementary school so i'm psyched
to finally be making a video
fully dedicated to naruto although i did
mention naruto in other videos like the
best geniuses in anime
link in the description if you want to
keep seeing naruto videos in the future
the best thing you can do is smash that
like button and share this video with
fellow naruto fans
let's try to get something cool like 4
000 likes on this video and
i'll get started on the next naruto
video asap if you haven't be sure to
subscribe
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you will miss future videos
keep in mind there will obviously be
naruto spoilers if you haven't watched
the series
yet now without further ado let's jump
into it if you somehow don't know the
hokage or
fire shadow is the leader of the hidden
leaf village he or she represents the
village
and protects the land of fire from the
shadows aka from possible
threats throughout the series becoming
hokage has been naruto's goal and by
extension the goal of every naruto fan
so obviously when the elementary school
teacher asked us what we wanted to be
when we grow up
we said hokage believe it this is the
most iconic position
in naruto and probably one of the most
iconic positions in all of anime and
that's one of the things that makes this
topic so interesting there have been
seven hokage thus far and it makes sense
to start with the first
hashirama senju hashirama senju was a
member of the legendary senju clan
and was referred to as the god of
shinobi titles don't get much more epic
than that
he formed a hidden leaf village with his
childhood friend and rival madara
and the rest of the jihad clan hashirama
actually wanted madara to be the first
hokage but the people chose him
hashirama was considered to be the
strongest shinobi of his era
even stronger than his legendary rival
madara a master of the op shutting gun
and the controller of the nine-tailed
fox hashiram is so associated with
overpoweredness that saying an enemy
character has hashirama cells has become
synonymous with saying their ob
as we'd expect the first hokage had
amazing stamina healing
and strength we can't go over every
technique in this video but let's look
at some highlights
we know that he's known for wood release
aka wood style moves
a nature transformation keke genkai
which combines
earth and water in his sage mode he
could use the attack sage art would
release
true several thousand hands to stop a
nine-tailed fox and sousa no combination
one of the most op combinations in the
series his will is strong enough to be
able to easily
undo the binding of orochimaru's
perfected impure world reincarnation
jutsu orochimaru singles him out
as being on a different level even among
the hokage he could fight 24 hour
battles and keep going which reminds me
of one piece where some fights can
straight up last for days
although hashirama often uses a
combination of earth and water release
he can actually use all five basic
nature transformations including fire
lightning and wind and beyond that he
can use
yin and yang release too he could put
tailed beasts to sleep and create
dragons out of wood that would
wrap around and absorb an opponent's
chakra and obviously beyond ninjutsu
hashirama was an expert in thai jutsu
and could even use genjutsu to trap
opponents in infinite darkness
now let's look at his little brother the
second hokage tobirama
senju tobirama was the realist where his
older brother was more of an idealist
the brotherly relationship is a fun one
where tobirama respects his older
brother but also criticizes him for
being foolish and naive at times he was
quicker to clash with ochiha clan than
his older brother but he did come to
respect and help some
chiha including sasuke during his time
at sokage there was no one greater than
tobi rama
he might not have been as strong as
hashirama but he was referred to as the
fastest
ninja in his time he could put
explosives and space-time ninjutsu marks
on you
before you would even know what hit you
tobirama also invented the shadow clone
jutsu one of naruto's favorite moves
toby rama can sense exactly how many
people are around and their strength by
placing his fingers on the ground he can
sense chakra from far away and even
identify whose chakra it is
like hashirama he could use all five
basic nature transformations and yin and
yang release but he was specifically
known for his water release
being a water bender of the highest
class he could use water to cut
form sharp needles perfect for hitting
vital points form dragons made of water
create walls for defense and much more
there doesn't even need to be a body of
water present
for him to aquaflex on his opponents the
genius tobirama
created the space-time ninjutsu flying
thunder god technique as well
which let him teleport to any place he
marked this
allows him to teleport other people or
things along with himself but that takes
extra chakra a cool detail is that
flying thunder god technique users can
work together like tobi rama and minato
did
and use one another's teleportation
locations tobii rama was clearly the
einstein of ninja techniques
as he also invented the impure world
reincarnation summoning jutsu he used it
in combination with another creative
technique called mutually multiplying
explosive tags which allows the immortal
reincarnated body to become a medium for
a continuous chain of consecutive and
multiplying explosions
another interesting thing about tobirama
is that he was big on strategy even
though he was strong
he wasn't above sneak attacks or
catching an opponent off guard
he would do what it took to win even if
it wasn't pretty and even though he
wasn't as strong as hashirama what i
really like about this series is that
toby rama
still comes off as an epic character
with his own strengths which included
speed technique creation intelligence
and more
next we have the third hokage and
student of the second
hirozen sarutobi the old man that's
actually hokage when the series starts
as with the first hokage the third was
also referred to as a god of shinobi
unlike the previous generation who were
part of creating the hidden leap village
saratobi grew up in it his childhood
rival was donzo who ended up becoming
one of the most
hated characters in naruto even more
hated than sakura
when sarutobi was still young his squad
led by the second hokage was cornered
someone had to be the decoy and
sacrifice themselves to save the others
and sarutobi offered to do it since he
was the strongest of toby rama's
followers
tobi rama ended up doing it himself but
we must pause and respect the level of
sarutobi's bravery
even as a younger ninja before toby rama
left he said that sarutobi would be the
third hokage
he himself had three famous disciples
tsunade orochimaru and jiraiya
as hokage sarutobi was not only the most
powerful shinobi in the village
but also the strongest kage iruka sensei
referred to saratobi as the strongest of
all
and said he was called the professor
because he was such a genius
in fact orochimaru said that sarutobi
knew how to use
all of the jutsu that exists in the
hidden leaf village which is insane
when iruka sensei referred to him as the
strongest of all he was referring to
sarutobian as prime which is probably
why he used the past tense even though
the third hokage was present
as in one piece old age leads to a
decline in power in this series
and the hokage is already in his late
60s when the story begins
against suroshimaru sarutobi lost or at
best got a tie
but orochimaru admitted that sarutobi
would have been able to kill him 10
years earlier
so when he was about 59 still even at 69
sadotobi is smart enough to realize that
even if he doesn't have the strength to
pull out rochimaru's whole soul
he can at least take his arms so that
the snake man can't use
jutsu and keep fighting this dude at the
age of 69
sacrificed himself and found a clever
way to save the village he loved so much
you gotta respect that it was said that
sarutobi had a lot of chakra before but
it reduced an old age to the point where
it was dangerous for him to split his
chakra with more than two shadow clones
luckily he was amazing at chakra control
so he could make the most of his low
chakra reserves in old age
sarutobi didn't just master jutsus he
also helped to advance them and he could
quickly break down a jutsu he saw for
the first time
and figure out what made it tick like
the first two hokage sarutobi
could use all five basic nature
transformations along with yin and yang
release
he could release streams of fire rock
water wind and lightning with no problem
it feels like every famous anime has a
character associated with monkeys
in dragon ball z it's goku and in one
piece it's monkey d
luffy and naruto with sarutobi who could
summon the monkey king enma enma could
transform into a staff that was
sarutobi's weapon of choice although it
was a bit too heavy for him in his old
age
the staff was hard as diamond and could
extend and of course i have to mention
dead demon consuming seal a sealing
technique that even
rochimaru didn't know about the
technique summons a shinigami
and in exchange for your life you can
seal away an opponent or at least part
of an opponent
it seems you could even escape the whole
sacrificing your life inconvenience
if you use a shadow clone to perform the
technique which is how sarutobi stopped
the first and second hokage
after they were brought back the first
time by rochimaru next up we have the
fourth hokage minato namikaze
he's naruto's father and kind of made
the whole naruto as an underdog orphan
narrative change
into naruto is the chosen one with op
parents narrative minato took over for
sarutobi for
a while until he sacrificed his life to
save the village by sealing a part of
the nine-tailed fox into his son naruto
he was called konoha's yellow flash
because of his remarkable speed he was
actually part of jiraiya's team when he
was younger giving jiraiya a sort of
grandpa grandson relationship with
naruto jiraya said that minato was a
rare genius the kind of genius you don't
see often
the raikage admitted that minotau was
faster than him and that a finer shinobi
than minato never lived when the threat
of orochimaru loomed over konoha
it was suggested that minato could have
stopped him if he was only still alive
he really made use of the second
hokage's teleportation jutsu in fact the
second hokage mentioned that minato's
teleportation
is even better than his he used it on
himself and he even had enough chakra to
teleport a tail beast
he was also able to summon gamabunta
like naruto after him
also like naruto minato was known for
using the rasangan
he actually spent three years developing
it after he observed a tailed beast ball
unlike the previous three hokage
mentioned minato could not flex with all
five nature transformations but he could
use
fire wind and lightning along with yin
and yang release
before he died minato became the jin
turiki of the yin part of the
nine-tailed fox
after his reincarnation he actually uses
nine tails chakra mode which further
strengthens all of his attacks
lets him fire beedru balls aka tail
beast balls
and more although he could also use sage
mode he's admitted that it takes him too
long to build up chakra for it so it's
not super practical
and unlike naruto the dude was very very
intelligent and had the highest scores
in academy history all of this
definitely makes a solid contender for
my favorite hokage
as we discussed the third hokage went
out of retirement when the fourth
sacrificed himself to save the village
after that the fifth hokage was the
first female hokage
tsunade she's a descendant of the senju
clan the clan that the first two hokage
came from
and she was also related to the uzumaki
clan she was one of the legendary three
along with jirai and orochimaru who were
trained by the third hokage
she was considered the strongest female
ninja and the greatest medical ninja
tsunade's life force and healing powers
are so strong that she could survive
being split in half
she could help fight against madara for
hours upon hours
she's a great fighter and she's usually
healing people on the side too
like her ancestors tsunade had amazing
reserves of chakra
and she even has great chakra control
furthermore she can store
chakra into the seal in her forehead
when released she can supposedly access
100 times the chakra she usually has
access to
her physical strength is off the charts
and she even managed to break through
the susano
with enough hits beyond that she managed
to break six of jorah's ribs his arms
and to rupture his organs instead of a
toe that developed tsunade can summon a
giant slug named katsuya
katsuya can split up into smaller pieces
in order to move protect and heal people
tsunade can connect to katsuya and thus
heal people remotely with her dried
reserves of chakra tsunade can use
four nature transformations including
lightning earth fire and water
as well as yang and according to the
anime yen release
one of the most interesting things about
tsunade is that she is 50
but uses a transformation technique to
maintain the appearance of a woman in
her 20s
like jewelry bonnie from one piece
tsunade can change her age to trick
people
especially when she needs to escape from
gambling debts her transformation will
remain
until she completely runs out of chakra
then she will revert to her actual age
tsunade was the medical ninja who
managed to fix rock lee
who might have never been able to be a
ninja again if not for that difficult
operation
knew that she could heal his arms if
anyone could
tsunade also invented the ultimate
regeneration technique called creation
rebirth which releases so much
chakra that her wounds heal right as
they happen the normal healing process
is insanely accelerated to the point
where it's as if the damage didn't even
happen
next up we have the sixth hokage the
very very popular
kakashi of the sharingan which is ironic
because he doesn't actually have a
shotgun
as the hokage kakashi is from the hatake
clan rather than tho chiha clan
he had a shotting gun because he got it
from his childhood friend obito we all
know kakashi as the cool leader of team
seven who loves to read jiraya's novels
kakashi was a prodigy before he
ever got his shot in gun eye he was
promoted to adroni
the level right before hokage at around
12 years old to put this in perspective
naruto is already like
13 during the trulian exams even before
he became hokage tsunade was saying that
if anything happened to her
there's kakashi to fill the role his
abilities were that obvious even then
when fighting him pain immediately
realizes how much of a pain kakashi is
and wants to defeat him immediately
because he can plainly see that he's a
threat kakashi is great at many things
for instance naruto said after the
timescape that kakashi was smart in
shikamaru
had a keener sense of smell than kiba
was more adept at the shotting gun than
sasuke
and had greater taijutsu than rock lee
kakashi is already a legend at the
beginning of naruto
known as the copy ninja who's copied
over a thousand different techniques
thus you can bet his knowledge of
ninjutsu is on point
rather than summoning a toad or a slug
he can summon up to 8 ninja dogs
yet another way he flexes on kiba these
dogs can talk
walk on water dig underground sniff out
an enemy hold them attack them and more
they are very versatile
kakashi can use all five nature
transformations along with yin and yang
release
the dude can create water dragons launch
fireballs and travel underground but he
is perhaps
best known for his lightning release he
can use chidori
cut lightning produce lightning clones
that paralyze opponents when touched
and so on he can no longer use his
s-ranked lightning cutter technique
safely when he loses his shotting gun
so he replaces it with a less powerful
but versatile purple lightning technique
another interesting piece of info is
that the shot and gun could not be
turned off by kakashi
and quickly depleted his chakra reserves
because he wasn't ochiha
that's actually why he kept his eye
covered back in the shot and gun days
without the powerful shotgun he does
have more chakra reserves to make use of
so it's not all bad news
when he still had obito's shot and gone
it had awakened into the mangekyo
shotting gun
and this one allowed him to use kamui he
could warp objects
and people into another dimension and he
eventually learned how to use it on
himself
when obito temporarily gave him access
to both of his mangekyo shotting guns
kakashi could also allow things to just
phase through his body and he could even
use
susano although kakashi of the shotgun
was dope af kakashi is great because he
was always so much more than a shot and
gun user
as mentioned he's more intelligent than
shikamaru a trait that is invaluable in
a fight
and his own skills got him promoted to a
jonine in record time the shine gun was
just a very epic
cherry on top of the cake and finally we
have the seventh hokage the titular
character himself
naruto zumaki once an outcast of the
hidden leaf village
he turned hero of the hidden leaf
village and arguably became the
strongest kage
ever he really started from the bottom
in some ways he failed to graduate from
the ninja academy
three times making him below average in
the beginning however he's come a long
long way and he obviously had his fair
share of advantages
if it was all about hard work being
enough then you'd see someone like rock
lee become hokage naruto had op
parents including the fourth hokage the
nine-tailed fox powers
and he was straight up the chosen one
still though if it wasn't for his hard
work and bravery
he may not have ever made anything out
of those advantages
and you have to respect him for that i
remember him defeating ki by nedji and
then working up to stronger and stronger
opponents
until he straight up saved the world
it's truly been a crazy ride for our
loudmouth protagonist
in regards to chakra reserve naruto has
a lot to work with
back in chapter 315 kakashi said that
naruto had four times more chakra than
him
and it would be 100 times more if yamato
wasn't suppressing the ninetails chakra
that in itself is insane to think about
as we know some of naruto's famous
techniques include shadow clones that
asengan and just going ham with the
power of the nine-tailed fox
in the fight between naruto and sasuke
where sasuke admitted defeat
naruto lost an arm along with sasuke it
was replaced with the help of hashirama
cells of course
and after some modifications the new arm
can even absorb techniques
in regards to the nine-tailed fox kurama
and naruto being at jinchuriki
we find out that in the beginning he
only had the yang part of the
nine-tailed fox and he already had at
least 100 times more chakra than kakashi
he later gains the yin part 2 raising
his jin churiki powers even more
kurama even says that naruto's mom and
hokage died pale in comparison to his
mastery over the nine tails chakra nine
tails chakra mode
and then kurama mode where kurama
wholeheartedly accepts naruto
took the seventh holkage to a whole
other level in these modes naruto can
sense negative emotions
and even resist genjutsu naruto's tail
beast mode allows him to launch a
barrage of tail
beast balls at his opponent as well as
to heal people by touch
similar to a summoning naruto can
maintain his human form as kurama
appears and they fight as two entities
naruto also has a piece of every tailed
beast's chakra allowing him to draw
their skills and allowing the tailed
beasts to speak to each other through
him perhaps naruto's most famous and
deadly jutsu is the sexy jutsu which was
always super effective against uriah the
reverse harem version even helped him in
the fight against the final boss kaguya
in some ways proving to be even more
effective than even amaterasu
as mentioned naruto always has jiraya's
handed down toad summoning his insane
number
of shadow clones his rasengan which he
learns to turn
into the s-class technique when released
rasen shuriken
and he even becomes able to use multiple
rasan shurikens at once
when he gains six paths in jutsu naruto
can use
all five basic nature transformations
including yin and yang release
and he becomes able to fuse the six path
sage mode with kunama's chakra
in order to become ultimate golden
naruto the form i love to use
in jump force with his truth-seeking
orbs and his ability to launch powerful
biju bombs
and that's the evolution of someone
going from ninja dropout to world saving
ninja superhero obviously there are more
details about naruto's powers and that
of the other hokage that i could not fit
into this video without making it
ridiculously long
but if you want to go super in depth
into any one of them
or into any other character i can do
that in a separate video
just let me know what you want to see in
the comments also
let me know if you'd like to see this
kind of video done for the rest of the
kange for the akatsuki
or for another group altogether if you
did enjoy this video and want to see
more like it the best thing you can do
is smash that like button and share this
video
with fellow naruto fans remember i'll
get started on the next one as soon as
we hit 4
000 likes on this one if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
ring that notification bell or you will
miss future naruto videos and let me
know if you guys want me to catch up to
the borto manga
and make some content about that as well
lastly the youtube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently
so the help and support we're getting
from our anime opera patrons is now more
important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these youtube issues and who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
legend acknowledged by lord twigo
himself
efren a and the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alola natan
the world steelers acquire respect but
they have a jonathan king
desi d brandon of isles papa smurf the
school bus
king riser emperor otaku richie martinez
and thomas jones and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson king
zelda anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica kayla fond hinokami and water
bonnie park zodiar12 rathuen deora tien
huang
cynical kraken fulgus77 and deadly saint
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon.com
anime upcor and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get a name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime
life and of course dank memes so check
out patreon.com
anime outpour link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the youtube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space
[Music]
cowboys
[Music]
you